i'm just going to dive right in because
there is a lot that we can talk about
with ethical ai and i
consider it um
a cornerstone in in safe ai although i
am highly biased as well because this is
what i do
but i'm going to go over some of the um
the main principles in ethical ai and go
into some details on how you can
integrate it into your work
all right so the principles of ethical
ai i love this little infographic it was
created by harvard
and basically each one of these
different spokes represent
a an organization so somebody like
salesforce for instance but a government
institutions so like gdpr is in here i
believe and there are across industry
like ieee has a set of standards and
each one of these little circles is a
category or principle
and
what these boil down to this is a little
bit more nuanced than what i have here
on the side
is around um fairness accountability
transparency privacy security and human
rights and if the circle is lit then
basically the organization has included
it
and one of the reasons i like to point
this out is that you know there are
differences in which principles are most
important for a different organization
so when i was at intel
they create computer chips and so like
their their goals and their um concerns
are different than when i was at
facebook which is like a social media
platform which has a ridiculous amount
of data and lots of different issues
than what i'm uh working with
now at salesforce which is um
a c2c
no a b2b a business to business type of
company so we sell our products to other
businesses who then use it to
make sure that their users are happy
with what they're offering in terms of
products or emails or
non-profit institutions use it too
and so
what uh
we've done here at salesforce and you
know like what you should think about in
your research in your labs uh when you
go off and you know maybe create a
startup or join a company is what are
the
principles that are most important to
your group and for what you're doing so
for us um this laid around a responsible
accountable
transparent
empowering um and inclusive so the
empowering one i think is a little bit
more unique for for our organization
because you know we're wanting to be
able to promote growth and employment
for our customers and their users etc so
you know empowering our customers to use
ai responsibly is
is something that's really really
important because a lot of times um
these customers are coming with their
own data and they need to be able to say
hey i know that you checked this model
when it was in your how when this ai
model was in your shop but now i have
changed it so is it still oh my god hi
panda this is my cat
he does this i've just learned to accept
it
okay cool so
why are ai ethics important um these are
some headlines and basically every week
there will be a new headline uh
about some sort of technology that's
gone awry and this could be
things like patrol robots in singapore
and actually this i just saw a tweet
about this with the recent lockdowns you
know people are afraid of their privacy
of
their safety etc
and then there's other issues like with
the ai itself like with the
labels that it might be putting on so
facebook
had an issue google had the same issue
of
uh ai putting the primate label on a
video or an image of a black person
it's like you know
it's like that's not okay and you know
if you're if you know computer vision
you can say oh well yeah i understand
why it made that mistake potentially
like the lighting was weird we didn't
have enough samples but at the end of
the day it's just not an okay thing to
happen
um
so it's important you we we have to make
our algorithms work for everybody um in
a way that's reliable and
doesn't you know like perpetuate the
systematic biases that we've had in our
society is what it boils down to
so
and one of the the biggest
issues around this though is that you
know like technology is dual use so we
talked a little bit about you know like
image labeling can have some very large
ethical issues you know and you might
ask okay well maybe we should just not
do image categorization or personal
identification is a great example
um
it's super helpful to unlock your phone
or devices i use it frequently
for that and it has also been used to id
human traffic victims or people uh that
are actually
criminally minded etc
but and at the same time it can be used
for person tracking it can lead to a
lack of anonymity a denial of entry or
service for different individuals
etc
so there's both of these coins so
what do you do about
this um
you should ask you know is my project
ethical and one way that
we go about that
uh at salesforce on a regular basis and
many others also do is to conduct like a
consequence scanning brainstorm uh this
comes
from.everyone.org and there's there's
varieties of uh
types like this but basically what
you're asking is what are all of the
intended and unintended consequence both
positive and negative
and for those that are negative how can
i avoid this this risk basically
so i'm going to point i'm going to like
walk you through
a thought experiment let's say we have a
factory where we're creating cars or
something and the the manufacturing
company is considering installing pose
estimates
pose estimation software
in their plans and
they're doing this because they want to
be able to detect if there's going to be
a collision between a person
and
the associated machinery so like you
know these cars go forward stuff can
drop down
there's a lot of moving parts and pieces
and this could detect fatigue
which you know together reduces the
number of accidents by prompting you
know an additional break maybe it
tells the plant owner hey there's been a
lot of
like potential incidents or incidents in
this area maybe we want to rejigger it
at the same time as you know like
preventing these accidents
if installed all employees would be
monitored for the duration of their
shifts and you know the the plan owners
have decided yeah we should
delete data after 72 hours except for if
an incident arose but
there still could be some issues here so
what uh i've done here with with a
couple of others in my group is ask you
know like what are some of the intended
positive and negative consequences so
basically
on the positive side we could have fewer
accidents on the site lower worker
fatigue you know company has to pay
lower workman's compensation overall so
here i'm looking at both the positive
consequences to um an individual you
know like no one
well
very few people would actually want to
get hurt on site i probably can't say no
one because there might be somebody um
and the company also benefits
but you know some of the negatives is
that now our employees are under
constant surveillance
and there is a cost to install and
maintain the ai system
and then once i like go through some of
the intended consequences i want to
think about some of these unintended
ones so these are you know like the
secondary consequences that might occur
if
i didn't initially
think about them and
some of the ways that you can come
around to this is talking to a lot of
people that's
you know 90 of my job
even though i'm a data scientist is
talking to people trying to figure out
like what is this system actually doing
talking to the stakeholders trying to
figure out like okay what are you
concerned about what are you excited
about with this system and then you know
having a discussion
so one of the positives is you could
have higher worker diligence and
productivity um because the people know
that they are being monitored
or
simply because they're excited about the
system etc
but a negative is that you know like the
um workers might not have any say in
this and so they could lose their job if
they're not comfortable with the
technology if you know the company says
thou shalt agree or leave
that could have some very negative
repercussions on the workers
it could be easily misused by estimating
worker productivity and salaries could
be impacted um
but this we have seen in uh
in shops especially um workshops
especially in china
or we've heard anecdotally i don't know
if we can prove it quote unquote but
uh also the system might not work as
accurately for all um video
systems import so anything around the
computer vision
arena works best for those with lighter
skin tones than those with darker skin
tones in general and also if you have um
if you're
you know disabled in any way shape or
form then it might not work as well for
you especially with pose estimation
software
and then another one you have to think
about is hackers could access this video
stream somehow you know it's
it is not out of the realm of
possibilities
so you start to think about this and and
you you go through and try to figure out
um
how likely is it going to be to happen
how many users are going to be impacted
the frequency that it could happen and
basically these other types of like
con risk
um
forecasting to try to figure out you
know like
which one should i focus on
most to rate them
and then looking from there to say okay
well what are some strategies that we
could mitigate the negative consequence
so
one of the biggest one is acquire work
consent and input um
make sure that it doesn't recognize
people uh maybe it blurs out the faces
of people it alerts the station that a
break should happen
soon instead of an individual or
something doesn't log any information on
worker fatigue uh
different things like this you know can
help um mitigate the risks
uh
so yeah
that's basically like what
you can do um and this sort of addresses
both like
overall like ethics as well as it it
starts to talk about like human rights
um
but yeah it's a really interesting
exercise to go through and i
i highly encourage it
okay i am going to move on to bias but i
might pause for a minute to see if there
are questions and i'll go and i actually
have a quick question um so this this
checklist procedure um seems like a
really great idea and i was just
wondering like is this something at
salesforce that that is done widely like
on any of the the projects and then is
it facilitated
by someone who has experience in it or
is it something that like teams just
kind of conduct on their own as a norm
for uh yeah
no that's a great question um
it is done regularly and it's done for a
variety of projects whether it is an ai
project or just a new feature
which could be ml or rule based or
whatever
and we do train
moderators to help
guide teams and i've i have found it
useful
to sit in the room for a couple of them
just to get the sense and feel of how
how these types of workshops are done
um but you know the
the way that it's structured and you
know like dot everyone.org did a really
lovely job of creating enough material
to support
somebody um in
in this type of endeavor
the other thing i would definitely say
with it is like
there can be a ton of imposter syndrome
around this like if you're
not a trained ethicist or whatever then
you might be saying oh i can't moderate
one of these but you know just by
bringing up the questions and asking
you know is this project okay to do and
getting people's input um
makes you
like an ethic like an ml or an ai
ethicist or whatever you want to say um
so
so yeah yeah
anyone can do it long story short
yeah hello a question over here um
hello
um i guess i don't know exactly how to
phrase it but how about this like it
seems to me like a lot of the problem
here is that if there is more
information available for a decision
making system
um we can't guarantee that it won't be
misused
and it's kind of similar to like other
things like so like you were saying
um if you're monitoring people like a
hacker can see it but if you're
monitoring people you can't prevent
management in five years from doing
something exploitative yeah kind of in
the same way where like i don't know if
if people are carrying firearms you
can't prevent that from firearms from
ending up in the wrong hands yeah is
there room for
having access to more information but
protecting it
and guaranteeing that like good agents
are using it or is that kind of like is
this the fundamental issue
yeah
no that's a great question and i do
think it is a fundamental issue and
there are things that you
could do
so
you can make sure that when you are
you know loading in the video before
your data is even stored in any way
shape or form that you have like a face
blurring or a face blocking type of
algorithm so that you
have um
protected some of the privacy you could
have very strong
access control list type of scenarios so
that you are ensuring that only those
who
absolutely need to get this data get it
um
and then you could also
get
into the
realm of like legality
so basically
uh
signing having like the lawyers of your
company draft and then have you sign
something saying like this data shall
only be used for these types of things
and basically making a contract with
yourself that's legally binding that's
really strong um
and
makes companies nervous sometimes but
you can do stuff like that too
but yeah it's it's hard because a lot of
times when the data
is out there um like i'm a data
scientist and i love data and i love new
data and i love glomming on data
together because it's
it's fun and interesting and tells me
things that i didn't know beforehand and
tells like whoever i'm helping out
new things but
like the awareness part of it also has
to be there
one thing i'll talk about later are
model cards um and data cards and so
those also go into like
um
aspects of
the intended use of data sets and models
and unintended etc so that that type of
communication is really helpful too
thank you now thank you for your
question
hi um i was wondering at sale for
salesforce in particular as a b2b
company um how much of this is like
weighing your own products you're
building versus considering your clients
and who's actually going to be using
your products and how is that different
yeah so um
i guess like there's two things in there
like we have a lot of global models
and so basically those are models that
we train on all of our data and so then
we make certain that
well a lot of that comes around bias you
know all honesty but we make sure that
the the usages and the examples that we
give to our customers are um
are ethical or as ethical as possible
and then we also provide them tools in
the form of um training modules and i'll
talk about our acceptable use policy but
well maybe i'll talk about it now but
basically like things that we
they
they may not do with our technology so
for instance um
this
oh oh it's sorry fast the you know face
re-identification example that i give
that's something that our
other businesses can't use with our
software because we just found it to be
to ethically issue have too many issues
basically so
um but yeah we focus on both i guess
thanks yeah totally thanks for your
question
if i can ask one more question
yeah
um so i feel like often in this
ethically ambiguous domains one argument
that that some companies make is uh we
don't build the product you know this
more extreme way another company is
going to build the product take over the
market
and so right now or maybe also in 10
years from now where do you see like you
know maybe the law stepping in at some
point and how much law do we require or
how much can the company still kind of
bring from their own sites
no for sure that's a great question and
it's something that we've actually seen
shift a little bit with um gdpr
which came out
i don't know how many years ago probably
four ish years ago by this point in
europe which restricts um
companies that
operated in the eu i believe how they
handle data um and so one of the things
i think that
was
a side
benefit for us even though we don't live
there is a lot of a lot more explicit
consent around data that websites
collect
this idea of being the right to be
forgotten
et cetera but there are also
minimal uh
types of requirement around transparency
and bias testing
those are getting more and more um
there's more and more regulation that's
coming down the pipe in those areas uh
but yeah as sort of like a
software provider like
because we don't own the data there are
less things that salesforce is legally
compliant
to act upon um and i'm not a lawyer so
but i talked to a lot of lawyers all the
time uh and
but at the same time we're like yeah we
still need to be responsible we still
need to ensure that this is happening um
because at some point down the line
it's it's not going to just be like the
data owners that have these requirements
um imposed upon them but
but other organizations like ourselves
as well so and we're in a weird little
gray area where we do
create some algorithms too so um
it's a little bit of both
yeah
but hopefully that answers your question
yeah thank you
alrighty um so i'm going to go into bias
now
and
bias is really interesting and there is
it's a term that's like overly used so i
wanted to do some definitions here
so basically you have some
algorithmic bias so your systematic
errors in the model's prediction so
you probably have seen more than one
powerpoint presentation of um
looking at like accuracy versus bias
with uh
either darts on a dartboard or like
arrows in a in a target
but then you can also have things like
societal bias so this is preconceptions
of a person or group of people that can
lead to systematic advantages or
disadvantages um
so this could be
things around housing loans where uh
black and
asian and other
minority groups have had
disadvantages in certain regions or
across like the us in particular getting
the same types of loans as the caucasian
individuals
now when you talk about fairness it's
basically your systematic bias for a
specific subpopulation which mirrors or
exacerbates
social bias so basically what can happen
is if you
create like a loan application ai and
it's trained on your historically
historical data and that's biased then
your
ai system could be as bad or even worse
we've seen in some cases um as
as your um historical bias
and i talk about subpopulations here
it's these these are basically groups of
protected class variables which could be
race gender age uh or other variables of
concern like socio-economic class some
of this comes from the partnership on ai
and they're a great resource so um
yeah
one of the really uh
important aspects to note though is that
not everyone has the same ethical
principles and our conversation in what
is fair and what is unfair
is ongoing it's complex it's messy and
it can be really heated and then it gets
even more complex we are in practice
uh this is a
image from
the good place which is a glorious and
hilarious show by the way but basically
in here um chidiana gonier who is an
ethics professor
is put into a real life trolley problem
and
the the trolley problem has a lot of
different variants but basically
it it asks the questions like you are a
bystander on the road
and a trolley is coming down the tracks
now you can pull this lever
and
switch the the trolley from one track to
the other
if you don't pull the lever then one
person
or no five people will be killed um
because they're on the track and they
can't get off if you do pull the lever
then one person will be killed so what
what do you do it's it's basically
a question of objectives and like
uh
would you actually intervene etc and
there's
there's a large number of
variants but you know like
in the real world it's like you can
answer this in a classroom and you might
get a different answer than if you're
actually
standing there on the street
and ai can be biased in
like a lot of ways basically it's you
know
bias can be all the way down sort of
like turtles are all the way down
but
who gets access to the benefits and
service um what is the purpose of the ai
you know like who's going to be impacted
your training data is a big one
so the representation of everyone
impacted your historical bias
and then uh your model too if
you include
uh subpopulation sensitive data in your
model
then it could exacerbate it in a way
then if you um leave it out
so
this diagram sort of goes into
a little bit more data representation
of our sources of bias um and i went
through them but uh this suresh and
guitar paper is
is helpful and if i haven't already
given y'all a list of references i'll
make sure to do that so you have it
but
yeah bias can get and everywhere and
what you want to do is is check so
you know
check to see what are
some historical biases that could be
occurring when i'm designing the system
how am i selecting my data if i'm just
scraping off of twitter or off of
facebook then who are the users of those
systems and
does that represent all the people that
i'm wanting to talk to or is it not
representative
quick question um we're wondering if you
guys actually
bake any of the bias testing into
whatever cicd pipelines y'all have
it is in some places but that's that's
also my job is to make it into more of
the places
so we have a tool called einstein
discovery and
that one has baked in um a lot of really
good tools for the end user
one of the really interesting things
there is that it's basically like um
a logistic regression fairly simple
type of algorithm well i shouldn't say
simple it there's a lot on the back end
but
it helps step a user through to make
sure that they do have representative
data um and then it does some bias
checks on the model that it then gives
to the to the like data owners so a lot
of times like
at salesforce we don't actually see any
of the data
but but yeah we've been systematically
going through a lot of our
other
uh models and
trying to check for it too
so do you do like unit testing or is it
just like um like is it just going down
a checklist would you actually run it
through like test cases yeah so some of
it could be done in unit tests um
a lot of the questions
that actually of concern that actually
crop up
more than the final like is this model
biased or not come earlier so like doing
the consequent scanning workshops
looking at uh who is applying the labels
how is the data
acquired those can't really be unit
tested so um instead we use like sort of
more of a checklist form
right but you could test um model
behavior on simulated data
yeah no for sure yeah
no and that and that's a great idea to
do and um
there's a lot of really good tools uh is
that my next slide it might be my next
slide
uh
no it's not i'm just gonna skip
that slide for now and i'll come back to
it
but
uh some of the open source tools that
are out there
are really helpful for exactly what you
were uh describing like ibm watson has a
fairness 360 and explainability 360
toolkit that can help you look to see
you know like are
are these models fair based on these
various subpopulations but there are
many more too so google has quite a few
and then these are just a smattering of
other github repositories
one of the tricky things though too that
you have to do with them um i'll go back
to this one is that there's like a
ridiculous number of definitions of
fairness
and the reason for that is different
situations um
are
harmful in different ways to an end user
so
you might if you're doing sort of like a
hiring or admissions type of
model statistical parity might be the
definition of fairness that's best
because you know it's basically saying
that there should be equal prediction
rates between certain categories but
that might not always be true for other
types of models um
so you sort of have to think of
think and figure out like what is
the definition of fairness and therefore
like the
um
[Music]
the end
metric that you are checking for in your
unit test
cool
and there is a ton of research in this
area and it spans all types of data so
there's a lot in nlp
computer vision as well as categorical
types of data and there's a good number
of data sets out there now which is
helpful so some of these are pseudo
benchmark types of data sets um and some
of them are built to test specific
scenarios
and we have
an ongoing list thanks to my my manager
kathy baxter keeps this blog up to date
cool so if you're looking for research
things that's a good one
okay i'm gonna press onward
i don't want to run out of time but
the
the next topic that i want to chat about
is around accountability and basically
once you're ready to deploy you want to
ask you know who is ultimately
responsible for how a system is used and
the decision it makes
and if there's a mistake that's made
how can it get corrected
how can a user appeal decisions that
were made by the ai system in this
appeal decisions that's another
regulation that is
has been enacted in the gdpr
there's a little bit less
csmds research in this area but
it's
it should be baked into every
type of project that you do um
and to sort of highlight this i'm going
to go through a case study
so
sharks you know
uh basically they're changing where they
swim and breed because of climate change
and
so
what
we wanted to do is um there's a benioff
ocean institute
it's founded and run or something by our
ceo mark benioff and they came to us
with the question is like how can we
study sharks and protect them while also
helping humans and sharks safely share
the ocean basically
we want less
shark human incidences on beaches
so
mj
here started this idea of shark eye so
basically use ai to detect great white
sharks to learn about their biology and
help people share the ocean with marine
wildlife
and
how accountability comes into place here
is
you know figuring out where a human
should be in this process
so a dispatcher can define territories
and the skills that are required to
collect data um oversee
that type of work etc and you know
there's data collectors so
uh
professional drone pilots who are
assigned territories and scheduled to
routinely survey areas of
beaches
sounds like sort of a lovely job
to have
um
and then you know like how do we
even make sure that you know like the
final ui that the drone dispatcher or
the
um expert at the end of the day is able
to look at this video and say okay like
do i trust it or not because ai is going
to make mistakes you know ai is not
infallible so
by showing you know like the bounding
box the prediction and um a percentage
you're able to really quickly convey a
lot of information because sometimes
it'll capture kelp as a shark and that's
not correct but you know it sort of
looks like a shark in some instances
the other thing it's not doing is making
any predictions about the person on the
paddleboard so it's not this model
wasn't trained on people
just on sharks
so again trying to like preserve privacy
then the last um
group
of people that are included are safety
workers um and these are dispatched when
positive sightings of sharks are made to
ensure people are safe you know saying
hey the beach swim beach is closed
there's a shark in the area et cetera
okay so some of the questions we asked
um is like how can this be used with
either malice or
alarming stupidity and i like the
phrasing of that because yeah you know
it could be done on purpose but it could
also be done
on terrible accident
who could be harmed so this is both like
the people on the beach the sharks
themselves um other wildlife like the
seagulls
there's there's a lot of stuff that goes
on on the beach
do we have enough perspective to
understand the risks and if not
who can we bring in to supplement it so
this is where we brought in the benny
off ocean institute we aren't shark
experts we're like data scientists it's
like yeah if you give me enough data
of
like oceans and beaches with sharks i
can totally build you a classifier that
can predict them um and it'll be fun and
it'll be glorious
but i want to make sure that i have
enough information
like what else could be in the water
how can we ensure privacy and yeah what
if there's drones everywhere
so
some of the considerations that we made
to like mitigate this this is basically
going through that consequence scanning
workshop again is you know
we're going to begin our recordings over
the water only because that's the area
of interest and the ai isn't trained on
people
we have certified drone
operators employed by the maniav ocean
institute so they're the ones that say
okay yeah these people can fly on a
beach and
you know there are
high-risk beaches are scheduled and
making sure that there isn't like
too many people on the beach flying
drones at the same time
cool
another part way to um
have accountability is
making sure that you are transparent and
that you have enough explainability
and one of the biggest things i've
learned in this area is that
just because i understand what's going
on doesn't mean that everyone else will
and there's like differing levels of
specif specificity technical details um
that are necessary in your documentation
so
you might need to have something very
broad for interested public versus like
your users
external collaborators or auditors and
the most information to your internal
team members like if i
submit a pr request
or if i submit a feature request i want
to provide
as much
information as i can
so
this is where uh model cards come in and
this is
with uh
accountability where accountability also
comes into play
and the reason i really like model cards
is that
they're very high level overview of
when a model was trained why i was
trained how it was trained
um
some of its ethical considerations where
it should be used where it shouldn't be
used so in you know like the great white
shark the shark eye example i want to
say this is trained on great white
sharks or this is trained on tiger
sharks and hammerhead sharks and so then
if um a researcher from another
institute is
using my model and they have
more sharks whale sharks
then they would know that they were able
or weren't able to use my model um in
which we retrain it or if they saw that
the model date was from like five years
ago and they knew that the technology
the cameras on their systems were much
better they would also change it
cool
any questions on accountability and
model cards because i'm switching just a
tiny bit
another um
i had one mark for transparency there is
a lot of transparency research and i
it's fascinating so
especially when you get into neural
networks or these really complex
ai algorithms
you need to start to figure out okay
well what in the world is going on and
there are some
uh
applications for feature importances
like lime and shop
as well as attention layers this uh
website from distil
is utilizing
attention layers i think it seems like
and basically it's highlighting where in
an image it thinks there's a labrador or
a tiger cat
the other really interesting thing i
feel like with transparency is that
depending on how much transparency you
need it might
sort of direct you to
a different type of model so for
instance cancer research there are a lot
of models that are starting to be able
to identify tumors or other
types of diseases in the body and if you
have a simple classifier
that says okay in this image i see
cancer or i don't see cancer well you
know like that's sort of useful but if
you instead
have like um
a segmentation model where you're saying
in this specific image of the picture i
see cancer or i see a problem then that
can really help
a a doctor or a technician much more to
be able to clue in and say yeah i agree
with the aai or i don't think the ai is
correct
so basically like
helping ai be a force multiplier for you
can
can really change what type of model you
want to deploy
and then i know there are a number of
students as well as um other per you
know professionals in here and yeah
ethics can be your career so there are
more and more startup companies uh
in both
that are doing this this is a smattering
of a few of them and there's also lots
of large companies that have ethicists
because
you know we as we've seen ai be utilized
in so many different ways we have really
realized that you know we need to do it
deploy ai in a safe um
an ethical manner
and then
if you know conferences and academia are
your thing and you know
then this is also really important
because it's focused on at conferences
more and more so these are a few of them
that have highlighted it but
um
nurips and icml in particular were a
couple of the first to require impact
statements so basically if you're
submitting a paper you need to now say
like what are the ethical considerations
of of this work
and a lot of the things that i
pointed out during this can be
helpful okay so last couple minutes i
want to leave you all with some helpful
tools and resources
uh
ethical ai is a huge realm um so you
know there are semester-long courses
that
deal with this and actually i
was given a handful of these by juan
carlos niebulles who is also a professor
at stanford
but one of the tools that i always
suggest is dion
dion is a basic cheat checklist it's
created by
driven data they're actually located in
the bay and it's
a checklist that's jupiter notebook or
readme ready so this can increase your
accountability and your transparency
again but it goes through a bunch of the
questions that
i raised and didn't raise and you know
helped you ask okay
if
i'm collecting data did they give an
informed consent
no is there
pii exposure what is what about our
collection bias etc all through all the
way through deployment and this is the
entire checklist so it can help you to
start to ask the questions that are
necessary
other tools i talked a little bit
already about the 360 toolkit um so i'm
going to skip that one
and these are some of the stanford class
classes that juan carlos
pointed me out to these are all i guess
in cs it looks like
but
especially things around ethics public
policy and technological change
things like this will really delve
deeper
into the history of um ai ethics why
it's important what we are doing about
it etc and there's very there's
more specific ones around nlp and i'm
sure
in the coming years there would be even
more
and
yeah salesforce also of course has some
things too the one
that i mentioned a little bit earlier is
this trailhead so base this is a series
of
courses that are self-guided and free
where you can um
learn a little bit more about ethical ai
what you can do in your product
and when i say product that's the same
as if you're doing a research project to
me they they can be very analogous
but yeah i think
that is all of them
um
definitely happy to take
questions
and
or dive deeper into anything
that y'all would like
wonderful thank you so much anna that
was a fantastic presentation
so maybe i'll kick us off with a
question so um i think much has been
made about explainability and
transparency tools
um for neural networks and i've seen
lots of really cool examples of it
working um i wonder
to what extent do you see them being
kind of
practically used
when you know like a data scientist is
actually creating a model uh do they are
they actually do they have real utility
there and are people using them
frequently
that's a great question um
i
i think that the way that they could be
used
the best and i have seen this in some
instances is
looking at failure cases uh
but even then
the tools aren't as useful as just
looking at the images so basically like
trying to figure out okay we're
if i'm doing a cat versus dog you know
classifier or whatever and i look at all
my failure cases and i find out that all
my chihuahuas are being classified as
cats because they're small
[Music]
then i might look to see okay well
what's going on with my training data
what's going on
with um
yeah i had to look at my training data
basically in that instance
and then be able to say okay well
how can i fix this and for that
i probably wouldn't need
you know any of these
fancy schmancy
transparency
um
uh tools because my eyeballs
are able to figure it out faster and
better than anything that we've built um
but
in other cases it might be helpful
uh yeah
i don't know i think a lot of times what
i mentioned earlier of
using a different type of model so a
segmentation model versus just a peer
classification model is
is more powerful and indicative to like
the end user as well as
the
uh
model designer so
yeah that's a good question
got it thank you yeah
yeah there's um
a researcher at google being kim and
she's been researching this for
researching like explainability and
in deep learning models quite a bit so
she might have a much different take on
it
than i do but
yeah
great
other questions for anna
so i actually have another one um
so you know a lot of folks here i think
are are researchers as well and a lot of
times that the things that we
uh build aren't
necessarily going to be um
kind of deployed very widely uh and
you know be actually interfacing with
people we will work on like toy problems
and stuff like that so i'm just
wondering like
uh there's probably a continuum of you
know how much consideration
you maybe need to put into
the design i think there should always
be some but maybe you know you should be
very much more certain when you're
actually deploying uh a system and stuff
like that i'm just wondering if you have
thoughts on like the continuum from kind
of academic interests all the way up
through like deployment and industry and
how maybe we can think about these
things
yeah totally that's a great question and
um
i think there can be research which even
if it's uh
just in academia can be quite harmful uh
and
this
mostly revolves around the ethical use
and not well some bias too but
some of the more recent examples is uh
things like gaydar so basically trying
to predict if from a picture if somebody
is gay or not gay or even just
predicting um
yeah it's so bad i saw some
cringy faces which i was glad to see um
even predicting like uh age or race or
uh gender can be really problematic
because these are
sociological constructs um
versus something that can really have
ground truth labels and that you know
a
image can really capture on for a lot of
different reasons
so like you know avoiding research like
that is good
for sure
um
but then if you get into questions of
bias you know like there
have been instances where
uh especially around reinforcement
learning you can create
images and if
i think it was
i don't exactly know what i think it was
going from like a pixelated image to
like a more full image or anyways
someone was able to
uh
use
research where the model was you know
put on to github etc and then pass in
pictures of barack obama as well as
other black individuals and
lighten the skin so i think it might
have been like a
glamour filters or yeah filters can have
problems too
so
so yeah there's there's definitely
areas where even if it is just research
it can harm a community if
you are
basically playing off of stereotype
historical stereotypes which have been
harmful in the past um or aren't true
for the whole population
or you're trying to
basically pigeonhole individuals into
societal norms that they don't believe
in um
one of the ones actually that i heard
about yesterday i think was
an age something that
aged people it's like what do i look
like when i'm in 50 years or something
and it was removing people's tattoos
uh
maybe because older individuals didn't
have as many tattoos unclear
but that was also
uh
harmful to communities where tattoos
were part of their heritage and their
culture um
so yeah
yeah it's
it's tricky
um and nlp has all sorts of
biases but um
yeah
uh
well word models they're getting better
i think i think we're starting to solve
some of those but
basically like
you just grab things off the web and
it's
reflected in the work that you do so
yeah think about that and basically
think about the worst tweet that could
be made of your paper and be like okay
how do i avoid that for me yeah i like
that as a metric yeah
yeah i have a quick question so we have
a few more minutes so today we have kind
of an interface in this conversation
right now between kind of academia and
industry and i think everybody has
definitely a part of this you know uh
kind of ethical ai direction but what
would you like or what would you think
uh would be great to see from academia
as like a great result that maybe an
industry it's a little bit harder you
know to work for this direction
yeah that's a great question um
you know one of the
i don't know
oh one of the biggest issues is how
to
a lot of the bias work in particular
requires information
on
subgroup information
so i need to know
was this tweet that i'm predicting
sentiment on like what it was the age
the gender the race the socioeconomic
group etc
of the person so that i can check to see
if my sentiment classifier for instance
is biased against these different groups
but
when i'm thinking about privacy and
safety i don't want any of that
information
because it could be then personally
identifiable and i don't really want to
store it
and there's things i can do to to make
sure that that data is safe but
you know like how
how can i
you know like
in an aggregate way
check for bias
when i may not have
the metadata of this information or i
want to occlude
that metadata from
anybody else in my organization
so if you can solve that problem that
would be great but so if i understand
that correctly what you think the role
of
here is to develop new kind of
algorithms or mathematical
frameworks maybe so to solve a class of
problems like the one you describe
and this is more i would agree also that
this is more of a kind of an academia
thing and then the industry would come
and kind of put this into the
place in the in the world okay yeah
sounds sounds great yeah no for sure and
and there are other algorithms in terms
of transparency or in terms of
even though
admittedly i sort of said oh no
transparency methods aren't useful
except for model cards but
um
yeah there's there's a lot a lot that we
can do around that area as well as
better mitigation strategies so
like ai 360 has a couple of like
mitigation algorithms in it which
basically reweight
training data coming in or things coming
out uh
but what else can we do is that
how can we
optimize the accuracy
of
like the full model
while
trying to get
our quality metrics up because sometimes
there's a trade-off
you're trying to build build up the
predictions of a minority group and that
might make the majority group fall a
little bit which makes your
your end accuracy number fall a bit
which makes you know my pms and product
owners like freak out a little bit
yeah
all right so i think we're right at time
so let's let's think again again for
that wonderful presentation thank you so
much for being here